If you've been down in the dumps ever since
it was revealed that the upcoming sixth season
of History's drama series Vikings would be
its last, it's time to pick yourself back
up.
A new Vikings spin-off series has been announced,
and soon Vikings: Valhalla will be streaming
on Netflix.
But first, a warning: Spoilers for Vikings
ahead!
Before you start scrolling through Netflix's
thousands of offerings looking for Valhalla,
know this: No release date has yet been announced
for the series.
Considering that the show's existence was
only confirmed in November 2019, Netflix is
likely nowhere near announcing a start date
for the series.
For comparison, just take a look at The Witcher.
That show was first announced way back in
May 2017, but it wasn't until Halloween of
2019 - two-and-a-half years later - that Netflix
announced the release date.
That debut date, by the way, was December
20, 2019 - meaning it wasn't announced until
less than two months before the premiere.
While Vikings: Valhalla may not have quite
as long of a wait given that it's spinning
off from a property instead of building one
from the ground up, there's no reason to believe
that Netflix will announce a release date
for the show anytime soon.
It's also worth mentioning that, since Vikings:
Valhalla is meant to be a follow-up to Vikings,
fans won't see it until after the original
series ends.
But forget about the question of when you'll
see it; a better question is, what exactly
is this spinoff going to be about?
If there's one thing that Vikings has been
great at doing, it's killing off its main
characters.
Season 3 saw the deaths of Earl Haraldson's
widow Siggy and the priest Athelstan.
Vikings season 4 knocked off Ragnar's second
wife Aslaug, his friend and rival King Ecbert,
and most shockingly of all, Ragnar himself,
who up until that point had been the series'
main protagonist.
"Your father was a great hero.
Perhaps the greatest hero of our race.
And that is why we have answered your summons.”
As more characters were added in season 5,
the bodies continued to pile up, with seemingly
no character being safe from week to week.
By the time Vikings concludes its run, it's
possible that there won't even be any main
Vikings cast members left alive to return
for Valhalla.
And frankly, fans shouldn't expect there to
be.
It has been confirmed that the new series
will take place around 100 years after the
current show, meaning that even the youngest
Vikings characters will be dead and gone by
then.
Instead, Vikings: Valhalla will feature all-new
characters based on even more historical figures
from Norse legend.
Some of the main characters of the new series
will reportedly be such legendary figures
as Leif Erikson, Harald Hardrada, William
the Conqueror, and more.
Even though the 100-year time gap will make
things tricky, Alexander Ludwig has suggested
that his character, Bjorn Ironside, may not
have finished his Vikings journey.
Whether that means some kind of flashback
sequence on the new spin-off series or an
appearance in a potential feature film remains
to be seen.
It's just nice to know Ludwig isn't quite
ready to leave the world of Vikings behind.
Since the spin-off was announced only recently,
plot details have been scarce.
But that doesn't mean we can't make a few
educated guesses as to what kinds of stories
Vikings: Valhalla will be looking to tell,
since we know a few of the main characters.
And to do that, we'll look to real Viking
history.
Leif Erikson is arguably the most famous of
the lot.
He has a pretty big claim to fame, as he's
believed to be the first European to discover
North America - rather than that imposter
Christopher Columbus.
"You're a phony!
Hey everybody!
This guy's a great, big phony!"
Not only that, but Leif Erikson is said to
have done so a whole half-millennium before
Columbus sailed the ocean blue, setting foot
in a land he dubbed "Vinland" back in the
11th century.
Next is Harald Hardrada.
Born about 45 years after Leif Erikson, he's
regarded as the last great Viking King, having
fought for control of Norway and Denmark before
meeting his end during an invasion of England.
His successor, in some respects, was his contemporary
- the Norman King William the Conqueror, who
wasn't a Viking but claimed Viking ancestry
as a descendent of the one-and-only Rollo.
William conquered England following Harald
Hardrada's defeat, becoming its king.
The pair's respective battles will almost
certainly factor into the plot of Vikings:
Valhalla.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.